receive the honor and support that they
have earned
next year i look forward to being with
you on fifth avenue again
for a more traditional parade but until
that time
please continue to remember those who
served
those who are serving today and every
day thank you
stay safe and may god bless the united
states of america
and those that love and protect it
now taking the podium is ken fisher
co-chair of the intrepid
sea air and space museum
good afternoon i'm honored to join with
the united war veterans council
and all who gather today to salute those
who were
who served our nation in uniform it's
feeling that i speak from the deck of
this aircraft carrier intrepid
herself a veteran as susan noted earlier
this great ship shed blood 250 intrepid
sailors
gave their lives for our nation on these
very decks and in the skies above
this great ship that gave birth to two
free women in public private
partnerships
the fisher house foundation and the
intrepid fallen heroes fund
who since their founding has continued
to aid our wounded veterans and their
families for 30 years now
the intrepid's motto to honor educate
and inspire has never been more relevant
than today
intrepid seeks to honor service to
country not only by those who wore the
uniform
but their families as well especially
those who made the ultimate sacrifice
it seeks to educate those who walk her
decks about the selfless service and
sacrifices made
not just by the one percent who served
today but by those who served in wars
past
and it seeks to inspire our public
school youth to reach new heights
through our award-winning stem
programs and the space shuttle
enterprise an intrepid will forever
serve as a reminder to stand up for
those who stood up for us
and support their families in times of
hardship
all americans share in this duty
just as those who serve take an oath to
defend this nation with their lives if
necessary
we too must take an oath to care for
them should they be wounded in doing so
and to care for their families if they
don't come home
2020 has been a challenging year for
reasons we all know
our nation is deeply divided in so many
ways
but let us stand together on this one
day
set aside to honor those who have served
because saying thank you for your
service is just not enough anymore
god bless our veterans god bless those
in harm's way
and god bless the united states of
america thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
commercial break please stand by
[Music]
oh
hmm
all right
[Applause]
please stand by
our next speaker is the honorable
philippe
the ambassador of france to the united
states
dear mayor de blasio dear veterans and
friends
it is an honor and a privilege to take
part in these veterans their
commemorations
i am here to salute both veterans and
active military members
for their service friends america's
oldest
ally wants to pay tribute to all that we
we have accomplished together going back
to the
u.s war of independence
then two world wars the creation of
institutions
that have promoted peace and democracy
and combating terrorism
this year we commemorate the 75th
anniversary of the end of world war ii
i want to acknowledge the great debt
that france owes to the millions of
americans
who served during that war their
commitment to freedom
and democracy saved millions of lives
it saved my country's independence
but as the french president emmanuel
macron has said
we owe to the soldiers who fought on our
behalf
more than our gratitude we
owe it to them to prove ourselves
worthy of the great legacy of peace and
democracy
that left us by strengthening
the alliances between free peoples
nourishing nourishing the attitudes that
allow liberty and democracy to flourish
reinforcing the international
institutions
that allow us to resolve our differences
peacefully and continuing to strengthen
the long-standing alliance between
france and the united states
and now i invite you i invite you to
meet
a group of world war ii veterans
that received france's highest military
award
to honor them for liberating my country
their stories represent the highest
expression
of the long-time friendship between our
two nations
generation the french legion of honor
awards two
open world war two battles for their
role in helping worldwide
is
the highest questions
he's
they should have been friends
over the last few weeks the first
sponsorship has also honored world wars
ladies and gentlemen the honorable bill
de blasio mayor of the city of new york
everyone it is an honor for all of us to
be here on the deck
of the intrepid but we know next year we
will march again
through the streets of this city to
celebrate our veterans today we
thank we salute our veterans we thank
all
active duty military for protecting us
we thank our first ally france and we're
honored to be here with ambassador
etienne
and i want to offer a special thanks
from the people of new york city
to vice admiral john mustin to him
for what he has done but to all the
members of the military who were here
for us
in our toughest times this spring in
this city when we were the epicenter of
the covid crisis
i want us to remember how our military
was here for us
i want us to remember that day when the
usns comfort steamed into our harbor
how that gave us hope how that gave us a
belief we would
overcome the challenge everyone who
served us at the javits center but most
especially
i remember the moving experiences i had
at our city hospitals
where we saw military reservists nurses
and doctors and
medical experts there to help those in
need
and i'll tell you something admiral i
saw many a navy
insignia at those hospitals i remember
elmhurst hospital queens in particular
the joy and the strength it gave
to our medical personnel when those
reinforcements from our military came
the heart it gave and the ability to
keep moving on so everyone
today we thank all who serve us
and we remember them on veterans day and
every day
i say to all of you who serve thank you
and god bless you
this year's featured service branch is
the united states navy
we are honored to present a message from
admiral michael m gilday
chief of naval operations
a special thanks
is
and now introducing this year's grand
marshal
jared lyon president and ceo of student
veterans of america
and a u.s navy veteran
good afternoon on behalf of united war
veterans council
and the more than 1500 student veterans
of america chapters
that we represent in all 50 states and
abroad
as well as the more than 750 000 student
veterans
currently attending a university with an
sba chapter i'm honored to be with you
here
in the great city of new york aboard the
uss intrepid
in the united states veterans day falls
on november 11th
the anniversary of the signing of the
armistice which ended world war one
hostilities
between allied nations and germany in
new york city
this day has properly been commemorated
without fail
every year since 1919 and we will not
let this year be different
no matter what differences there may be
between us we all take pause today
united in our cause to honor those who
have so bravely defended our freedoms
for those of us who have lost someone in
service to this great nation
i'd like to take a moment to acknowledge
your loss
for those that have served wearing the
cloth of our nation
they've been drawn from the full
tapestry of american life
they were generals and privates captains
and corporals
petty officers and commanders from every
race color and creed
but we were all sisters and brothers in
arms united by our undying love for
country
what we do with this great gift of the
service that veterans have given
is today an opportunity to renew our
conviction
to live worthy lives to pursue our
aspirations
and continue to serve others we will do
so
in the honor of veterans and we will
never forget
thank you and happy veterans day
the replaying ceremony will be next when
the 2020 new york city veterans day
salute continues
ladies and gentlemen we're gonna we have
about six minutes to move into position
for the wreath-laying ceremony
our speakers and interviewees only could
make their way to the back
mark otto he has his hand up there he
will guide you through the
flower placing process of the wreath
ceremony wreath layers if you could be
in place
we have a little over five minutes to
get into position thank you very much
oh
oh